[Applause]  steal by Kristen who came from The Blind  Side Cookie Monster - cookies - raspy  green got back started out shooting at  Portland look vz3 the heart of the shot  sometimes the bad guy a little step-back  17-footer rebound wind out windows  really cleaning the glass and then  loving beautifully get it to green he  stripped as he was he and Chris done  came together both of them are trying to  shake it off Levine sports at the other  round mismatch with draymond Green he  comes over and no one covers for him  I'll be with a step back the offensive  glass out love the stutter step  dribble Drive goes inside he kind of  reminds you as the draymond Green side  the player but a better offense  Lavigne  [Music]  college town with all six points here in  quarter back again PJ came off that  screen again